so I think about death all the time it's
probably the thing that I think the most
about and I think that influences how I
see time and also how it influences
agency what actions I'm willing to take
despite the Judgment of others it might
be because I have more insecurity than
everyone that I think like man I want to
do this thing and then I hear all these
other voices of reasons why I shouldn't
do it or why somebody else will say
that's wrong whatever and so I think
I've had to come up with a lot of these
devices to get around my own
insecurities to take action despite
those insecurities and the biggest one
that I think about is that it doesn't
matter whether I achieve all of my goals
or I don't achieve of the goals in three
generations I'll be forgotten and the
only people who were naying against me
will also be dead